à les regarder en harmonie sur les
moments forts et le mot qui a fait le
plus parler sur les réseaux sociaux ça
c'est le mariage de nolwenn et floria
bhl et ouais ils étaient compatibles à
83%
ils se sont dit oui hier qui est mariée
ici qu'est marie d'ivoire s'est divorcé
et remarié et l'autre sans rigoler on a
l'impression qu'à une meuf oh bah moi je
suis forcément heureux mais moins des
lois de cajou 1 chez ta mère toi
[Musique]
je
faria
[Musique]
madame nolwenn josette eliane se
présente
confrontez vous à prendre pour époux
monsieur florian dessous présence
oui
alors thomas comment je me sens affligé
non je suis pas figé c'est vrai car la
photo du make way ils doutent des deux
dans les yeux au fond il dit on verra
[Rires]
mais tomba est ce que tu te rends compte
du truc c'est que le mec qui arrive mais
il arrive à tout le monde qu installer
tout une folle il ya les parents il ya
des amis tout ça c'est les parents enfin
je sais pas en tout cas il ya des
preuves et dlc pour et le but et se
porte alors aimer par contre le mariage
ne leur coûte pas un homme et son péché
toucher un gros chèque pour le moment
ils sont non c'est pas les anges voilà
le mariage et pillé leur mariage un
travail à côté des échecs sentimentaux
ils font ça comme il maintient voire la
vie de jim et moi m sur cette émission
alors je vous cache pas que chez moi le
chef de famille tient la télécommande
c'est ma femme qui a été les commandes
donc moi je voulais pas regarder
elle m'a obligé à regarder cette
émission d'accord ils sont et vous vous
êtes comme columbo parler de vote ça va
toutes les phases et donc oui j'ai
regardé
ils sont libres finalement ils vont et
moi ce qui me choque c'est que souvent
des personnes un peu jeune on pourrait
dire qu'une fois qu'on a à g un clapet à
sa soeur et son fils ont globalement
jeunes qu'est ce qui fait que des gens
des sites fnac ou d'aller à l'aveuglé et
de se dire bon bah on y va donc à douala
castaldi non mais dès qu'on vécu
beaucoup de déception un vrai qu'il
n'est même plus à l'amour vous marier au
premier regard parce que vous on
rappelle ses dosettes tombe amoureux sur
appelé à prêter des noms mais vous savez
très bien je n'aime pas du tout cette
émission je trouve ça remet en cause de
mariage maintenant on a reçu le psy l'un
sur ce plateau qui essaie de justifier
ça parce que c'est une expérience
sociologique mais honnêtement vous avez
d un extrait je sais de l'admin 9 à la
solide en 2009 c'est d'une gêne ans
absolu ce mercredi mais quand je vois ça
d'ailleurs je vous le dis j'ai une
première fois je veux honnêtement qui a
passé une bonne heure fixe est pas alors
et vous vous sol et 12 nuits de noce que
vous avez des projets pas un souvenir
impérissable de la lune c'est vrai
mélanie beaucoup de personnes mais n'a
une bonne écoute est formidable a way to
hell à mon avis
zoom / by name à la fédé pois chiche
mais là les poncifs à tête de ma mère
était en train de faire une salle ou
bien un truc comme ça que tunisien
marocaine ouais alors une nuit de noce
aujourd'hui plus personne ne fait rien
le sens la nuit noces on a tellement
consommer avant que ce soit on est crevé
je suis pas marié mais je peux vous dire
la nuit de noce tu vas voir j'ai bien
fait car antoine ma gueule moi 40 ans 40
ans tu sois ma gueule je vous le dis à
ceux qui nous lie to me regarde et je
peux dire que la nuit de noce je peux te
dire restez pas dans les parages mais
thomas tiacoh adultes étaient bonnes et
tout cela mais qui sera la classique
jusqu'à la seconde était qu un rôle
aussi donc le mecredi pas dans les
parages vous dit
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya eu il ya eu le moment le
moment toujours attendu dans l'émission
c'est quand les candidats annoncent à
leurs proches qu'ils vont se marier
ouais c'est vrai parce que mine de rien
on va pas se mentir et je le dis à tous
les téléspectateurs cas c'est bien quand
ont pécho une meuf ou un mec franchement
le moment où la pécho je sais que le
moment où tu la pécho à quoi tu penses
tu penses qu'à un truc le moment où tu
vas à péter potes pour leur dire c'est
bon je les paie show bike show là là ça
y est c'est fait on est parti pour la
grande aventure
en fait ce que vous appelez vos potes
pour leur dire ça y est j'ai réfléchi
mais moi j'en vois mais ça le comme en
direct group est un groupe le monde là
même le patron de cevital un peu chaude
à ils sont quoi s en trouvait
d'administration chez vivendi
je crois qu'à nous a fait chaud quoi
important c'est apple qui toi
j'appelle personnes ça regarde personne
wawel où ça fait sens tant que t'as pas
puisque quelqu'un et naïma loge journal
el pais oui madame allons casser
l'ambiance est votre favori
mais thomas raison c'est affligeant
vincent quandalle ce programme là nous a
fait une ambiance est là avec tes
potassé le mercredi après midi et a
invité tous tes copains ils
atteindraient entre la beauté
[Rires]
moi tellement j'entends mener cette
bourde ont peur de moi que ça doit
sentir malade mais sur alibaba nous
amènera score on s'est entendus tard
homme qui met la clé dans la porte
non mais moi j'étais premier degré sur
ce programme que je trouve juste
scandaleux on considère les candidats
comme des rats de laboratoire
comme si l'amour ou comme si le mariage
c'est des réponses à des critères ça
n'ont aucune estime étant malin je
rappelle que les rats ne sont pas
consentant usi vont dormir moi j'ai vu
des rats comme attaquer leur droite
brice d'orange tu me diras qui vont
sauver sa promouvant la boj comprennent
pas ce terreau gioria claude qu'une
ambiance le temps avant il y avait des
mecs là tu vois maintenant il ya plus
personne qui va quoi alors yann au
moment où ils disent à leurs proches que
ça fait deux heures que je lancerai oui
non mais par contre là dessus vous avez
raison franchement 50% du truc de pêche
aux quelqu'un c'est le racontent et c
est bien sûr ça je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous font du gras will
smith à vos amis vous raconter beaucoup
plus triviale que ça super gaston c'est
bon c'est gênant
et vous vous dites ceux qui suivent
l'émission depuis longtemps on est à
dire qu'il ya deux ans c'est le sniper
de l'émission oui nous étions en
perdition regardez allô oui c'est moi je
sais déjà ce que tu vas me dire mais tu
sais que je faisais partie d'une
expérience
du coup en fait je voulais tu as annoncé
que j'allais me marier dans un mois est
ce qu'avec pape a dû vous accepteriez
tous les deux de venir à mon mariage
au moins pour me soutenir ne serait-ce
que ça
[Musique]
c'est dur quoi le dis parce que il ya
une part des mêmes qui espéraient malgré
tout les parents on change d'avis ou
soient favorables estime d'expérience
elle ya cru mais la femme là cette jeune
fille parle d'expérience mais le mariage
c'est pas une expérience pris 40 ans tu
marques c'est une expérience et par là
il est super cool
si oui mais c'est une expérience je vous
même alors christine kelly souplet alors
qu'il ya un petit peu de douceur dans ce
monde de brute et les parents ont
regardé l'émission et des parents disent
d'accord et finalement il m'a félicité
et a été pendant longtemps ils
regrettent d'en avoir parlé regretterai
pas j'avais à partir sur le csa comment
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai les parents
rien n'est donc ça c'est intéressant de
voir qu'ils n'étaient pas là mais qu'ils
ont quand même apprécié l'émission mais
autre niveau
c'est en tout cas ce que l'hôtel sun
dominé les champions actuels d'un demi
litre les coupes qui vont sur les
réseaux lario et caetera et ceux qui
sont une expérience tant qu'ils sont
volontaires
pourquoi pas après il ya le divorce oui
j'étais en clientèle mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez non mais ce que j'en pensais
qu'ils sont peut-être pas si tous des
villes et si naïfs qui ne le sont pas on
respecte aussi le choix des gens s'ils
ont envie d'y participer et qui trouve
ça con pour leur vie pourquoi pas est
juste les ponots le petit déjeuner c'est
le petit déjeuner citons salle jusqu'à
10h30 à l'hôtel avec merci non mais elle
adore cette émission vous adorez vous
avez regardé ailleurs moi j'adore parce
que je respecte le choix des gens de la
parfaite à moi j'ai regardé crime et un
moment j'étais fatigué je passais de
crime à mario bros me regarde je crois
que cela comme ce n'est marié qui avait
déjà tapé ce n'est pas comme si je
regarde crise tous les lundis moss a
crime sur un t2 meilleur tueur gars
crime frère on sonne chez what pour
n'importe quoi alors mais c'est un truc
de ouf ça te met dans une fosse mon
frère
je regarde le crime toile a dit mon
frère je suis comme à son frère l'a
alors tout seul sané ne l'abatte ans et
mourad qui m'a demandé où j'allais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]